hundreds of mourners gathered for a
somber homecoming in Northern California
Elena Housley was the youngest of the 12
victims of last week's mass shooting in
Thousand Oaks people lined the streets
yesterday to pay their respects to the
18-year old as her body was returned to
her hometown of Napa California Lee
Cowan spoke with her father uncle and
aunt sister sister star Tamera Mori
Housley about the heartbreaking loss my
daughter's body was brought back to Napa
today we're gonna we're gonna bury her
in four days I should not have to do
that but Eric house Lee didn't have to
do it alone lining the Napa streets were
hundreds of good-hearted folks who came
to welcome 18-year old Elena House Lee
home for the last time what was it like
for you guys to see that line of people
for over a mile I lost it and my wife
Hannah and I lost it the utter sameness
of this grim ritual is more than
familiar to Elena's uncle Adam Housley a
former Fox News correspondent I've been
to these things Lee you have you've
covered these things you go home and you
sit there and you're like you know oh my
gosh how these people gonna get through
it you know and now we're living in
Elena was beautiful
his wife and Elena's aunt actress Tamera
Mori Housley he's looking for answers
yes there needs to be a change but all
the noise nothing's been done and it's
because of that despite being in the
midst of so much grief that they all
agreed to talk to us
Elena they say would have wanted to dig
deeper than politics if I was to walk
out here the first thing I was to say
was you know gun control guess what
half the country conversation ends yes
we don't want the conversation in it it
can't this time we want it to continue
have you been able to wrap your head
around talking about her in the past
tense
yes how come we don't believe that her
voice will die we believe that that
there's a message that's out there
what's that message to us it's to to be
kind kind to one another it's to put
down your top your technology put down
your phones and look at somebody and
have a conversation it's not about gun
control this is this message is about
doing something bigger to be with your
community to love one another all things
that you don't have to legislate right
Thanks
exactly to get to the point we can have
a conversation about anything political
has to start here it has to start with
the soul because we've lost that what if
somebody walked up to the guy and just
asked him how he was doing that day and
ends and said hello to him or did
something that may have just changed his
mind
instead of ignoring or whatever we're
doing you know what people are gonna say
though is skeptics are gonna say it's
too simple that that sounds great about
being decent kind yep and reaching a
handout yep but I think most people are
gonna say it I think it I think it
starts there you start with imagining
wait a minute what if that was my child
or my niece or my cousin it'll get you
in a place of just having some sort of
human decency if there's any doubt
there's a deficit of decency look no
further than the family's social media
you should see some of the tweets we got
after Elena died ridiculous really oh I
got one you deserve it you worked at Fox
News and it got liked by about 78 people
you're kidding no no that impossible
divide the chasm that pundit suggests is
too wide for any bridge fade it away
but what Elena's family saw underneath
her final sunset back home in Napa what
she would want to happen is what
happened today
well we drove down that street I saw
people of all colors all ages people I'd
never seen I was born and raised in this
town hugging holding hands shaking hands
she'd want that to happen at national
level she wouldn't want this happening
to anyone else for CBS this morning Lee
Callan Napa California it's interesting
their desire not angry but their desire
to try and reenact some real reform
around a conversation I'm so
appreciative of them of them speaking
out when they are clearly in such pain
but I also think to myself why does
someone have to die for us to get a
message of being kind to each other why
does why does Elena or anyone have to
lose her life under these circumstances
to have people line up black/white all
colors and say this has got to stop
it troubles me greatly that we keep
having the same story with these same
interviews in the same pain and nothing
changes and I keep wondering what is it
going to take I don't know the answer to
that question I was surprised to hear
the father even bring up the shooter
yeah right yeah I had anybody approached
him and asked him how is anyone that
takes a lot of strength but that's he
said her voice did not die yep